- Welcome back to this third panel,
Incarceration,
Decarceration, and Education,
which is sort of formed around the notion
that universities in
particular have become centers
for prison education and reentry programs,
as well as abolitionist activity.
How can we foster such
programs in the future,
and how might they relate to
the decarceration movement?
And our four panelists here,
I'm gonna introduce them
very briefly all at once
and then let them take over.
First of all, Bernard Harcourt,
who's a multifaceted
intellectual and activist,
professor at Columbia Law,
founding director of the
Initiative for Justice Society
at Columbia Center for
Contemporary Critical Thought,
also, directeur dՎtudes
at the Ecole des Hautes
Etudes en Sciences Sociales
in Paris, the author of a dozen books,
brilliant editor of several
works by Michel Foucault,
lawyer for death row prisoners in Alabama,
and teacher at Rikers Island.
And he'll be followed by Antonne Henshaw,
who is director of the
Transformative Justice Initiative,
which he founded to support
the formerly incarcerated
on their release from prison.
You can see him on videos
at the gate of East Jersey State Prison,
the first degree to
embrace the newly released.
Antonne is also studying
for his master's degree
at the School of Criminal
Justice of Rutgers University.
Next, Zelda Roland, Yale BA and PhD,
who is the founding director
of the Yale Prison Education Initiative,
where she almost single-handedly
has made an enormous success,
including the award of
a large enabling grant
from the Andrew Mellon Foundation.
She coordinates the Yale program
with the Connecticut
Department of Corrections
and with a committed group
of Yale faculty and students
and with the University of New Haven.
And finally, our respondent, Ben Berger,
teaches political science at Swarthmore,
where he is executive director
of the Lang Center for Civic
and Social Responsibility.
And in this role, he's
focused the center's mission
on connecting the curriculum
with the community.
In particular, he's made prison education
a vital locus of engaged scholarship,
stressing the ways in
which students inside
and outside can co-create knowledge
and change public perceptions
and public policy.
So I'll say no more,
and turn things over to Bernard Harcourt.
- Thank you, Peter,
and thank you all for an
amazing conversation so far.
I'd like to start with a series
of epigraphs giving voice
to writings from the prison.
First is from George Jackson,
"Soledad Brothers," 1970.
"I met Marx, Lenin,
Trotsky, Engels, and Mao
when I entered prison,
and they redeemed me.
For the first four years,
I studied nothing but
economics and military ideas."
From his brilliant book,
"Blood in My Eyes," 1971.
George Jackson again.
"I would be sitting in a
special locked isolation cell,
sometimes even with the lock welded shut,
and there would be no one to talk to,
just the sound of screaming voices.
Because there's no human
contact, you depend on books.
No contact with people, special
lock welded on the door,
nobody around, I'm strictly by myself.
The only friend I had was a book.
Sometimes I'd find myself
talking out loud to the author.
I'd sort of wake myself
up and I'd hear myself
talking to this other person.
I guess it was some kind
of wish fulfillment.
When I'm asleep at night,
I still find myself
talking to those guys."
The next slide, yes, the next slide is,
the next epigraph is from Albert Woodfox,
a brilliant author of
"Solitary", the book,
"Solitary: Unbroken for Four Decades
in Solitary Confinement".
He spent four decades
in solitary confinement.
Sadly, he passed away a
few months ago of COVID.
The years in prison had
worn his health down.
He writes, in "Solitary",
"I turned cell into a university,
a hall of debate, a law school.
Reading was my salvation.
I first gravitated to books and authors
that dealt with politics and race.
George Jackson, Frantz Fanon,
Malcolm X, Marcus Garvey,
Steve Biko, Eldridge
Cleaver, 'Soul on Ice,'
J. A. Rogers' 'From Superman to Man.'
We read anything we could
find on slavery, communism,
socialism, Marxism, anti-imperialism,
the African independence movements,
and independence movements
from around the world.
Leaning against my wall in the cell,
sitting on the floor, on my
bed, or at my table, I read."
The next epigraph is from a letter.
It was a letter that was written
to Albert Woodfox by a man on death row.
And he'd sent it through his attorney,
George Kendall, an old friend,
and he'd sent a message to Mr. Woodfox
in this handwritten letter
dated December 9th, 2021.
I tried to edit out
some passages that were,
but here's where he
writes to Albert Woodfox,
O.G Shaka Cinque, which
was his name inside.
"I myself and some other
sociopolitically conscious comrades
have been having teach-in sessions
with your book, 'Solitary',
here on death row.
It is deeply inspiring and motivational
and we wanted you to know this.
An idea that just came to mind,
and you'll be able to see
a video of mine conducting
a demonstration on the 35th anniversary
of the assassination of George Jackson.
Just know that there
are brothers down here
and who stand in that righteous tradition,
and we are still fighting on.
Guerilla love and respect."
Cycles of regenerative
action, regenerative cycles,
spontaneous chain reactions,
permanent revolutions.
What's so remarkable about prison writing,
about prison reading, about prison study,
is the way in which the written word
in prison circulates and recirculates
and sparks and inspires and nourishes
and sustains new revolutionary cycles.
George Jackson encountered Marx
and Mao in prison and became,
as Dr. Joy James says,
"A dragon philosopher and
revolutionary abolitionist,
transforming himself
and his prison comrades
into the military wing
of a vanguard party,
The Black Panthers.
Albert Woodfox reads George Jackson,
right, as well as others,
"Mao's Little Red Book",
and he too is turned revolutionary,
co-founding the first official chapter,
The Black Panther Party behind bars.
Today, a person confined in death row
reads Albert Woodfox,
reading George Jackson,
and is rejuvenated in his
struggle against the oppression
of his confinement and
his sentence of death,
teach-in sessions in prison,
reading groups in prisons.
The cycle revolves rejuvenating
and transmitting the
passion, the commitment,
the struggle, the revolution,
generating new political praxis.
What happened in California
in 2010 was simply remarkable
with the Short Corridor Collective,
which was formed in the SHU,
in the secured housing unit, in isolation,
basically, in Pelican State Prison.
That was a collection
of men held in solitary
for being allegedly leaders
of different racial gangs,
including Todd Ashker, Arturo Castellanos,
Antonio Guillen, Satawa
Jama, Paul Redd and others.
And they formed a reading group
to discuss the works of
Bobby Sands and Cesar Chavez,
the Black Panthers, Michel
Foucault, and others.
And as Professor Allegra McLeod recounts,
she writes, "Although the men
could not meet face to face
or even see one another
from their solitary cells,
they were able to organize
and read the same text,
pass notes, talk to one another,
pushing the pages torn from these books
through the vents and the drains
and the cracks in the walls
so that they could share the texts.
And they were able to talk with each other
through the vents and
discuss and formulate
an understanding of their situation,
the way in which the prison administration
was using their racial
identities to control them.
A long journey that ultimately led them
to organize the country's
largest ever prison hunger strike
in 2013, involving more than 30,000 women
and men throughout California
prisons who refused to eat.
And ultimately, leading to
litigation and other organizing
that ended indeterminate
solitary confinement
based on gang affiliations.
Reading Bobby Sands,
inspiring them to action.
Also, what happened,
we were talking earlier today
about Jean Genet, right?
Who helps form the group.
(Bernard speaking in foreign language).
The Group of Prison Information in 1970,
reflecting particularly on George Jackson
on all facets of the prison
and the repression at the time in France,
but also in the United States.
And ultimately, fueling this text called,
"The assassination of George Jackson",
of which Genet wrote the preface,
but a text that would
be published in France
less than three months after
George Jackson's homicide,
right, as George Jackson
is killed on August,
I think it's 21, 1971,
and this book is published
by Galima with Jean Genet's
preface in November 10th of '71.
And it's remarkable, the way in which
all of these works inspired
others and philosophers
to rethink and rethink the
prison and rethink society
and had such extraordinary,
cyclical effects
on philosophers like Michel Foucault,
who, as a result of this
work and his engagement
in prison abolition in France at the time,
comes up with a completely different model
of our society based on civil war, right?
And he would write in
these important lectures
he delivered at the College de France.
"The matrix of all struggles of power,
of all strategies of power,
and consequently also,
the matrix of all the struggles regarding
and against power is the
matrix of civil war."
So, one of the questions
we pose ourself, of course,
is how we engage in
education in the prison.
And what's clear to me, of
course, is as critical academics
in our relationship to prison education,
which is one of the most
important aspects of our lives,
what's remarkable is that
these prison writings
and experiences really convince
me that the most genuine
and authentic academy
is the one that's created by
the women and men behind bars,
in solitary, on the short corridor,
at Angola or Parchman or Rikers, right,
in their reading groups and teach-ins
and their critical examination.
People behind bars form the true academy.
And you can hear this.
You can hear this in
solitary, you can see it.
It's tangible. You can feel it.
When a friend, man, friend
and man, Darryl Robertson,
is released from Rikers Island,
walking out of the New York
County Criminal Courthouse
at 100 Center Street
in downtown Manhattan,
carrying, as his only
property, his only possessions,
275-pound bags of books,
more than 100 books on
his back is the only thing
that had got him through
his time at Rikers.
It becomes clear that these
spaces built to confine,
to punish, to do violence
to men and women,
these spaces have turned
into, are turned into,
by the people who are prisoned there,
the true and genuine academy,
where critical thought and
debate is really most alive.
Sometimes I feel like our ivory
towers pale in comparison.
There isn't the same drive almost.
There isn't the same hunger,
there isn't the same need to read,
to critique, to engage in praxis.
And so moving forward, and as we think
about kind of education
and justice and education,
I think it's not always the question
of what we academics contribute
to the critique and praxis
of men and women behind bars,
but instead, how can
we, in higher education,
transform ourselves to better model
the relationship between
critique and praxis
in the true academy that
the people in prison create.
One final thought.
These prison writings, they
emerge out of the depths,
"De Profundis", as Oscar Wilde called it.
George Jackson himself
wrote from those depths,
"Capture," he said,
"imprisonment is the closest
to being dead that one is likely
to experience in this life.
Oscar Wilde also wrote from those depths.
And during his time at the Reading Prison,
he was so deeply affected
by the execution of a fellow prisoner,
he wrote "The Ballad of Reading
Gaol", the Reading jail.
On his release after two years
of incarceration for the
crime of homosexuality,
he signed it C33, that
was his prison number.
And so it appeared,
originally, anonymously.
I think I'll finish with a
verse from that beautiful text.
"This too, I know.
And why, as it were, if
each could know the same,
that every prison that men build
is built with bricks of shame
and bound with bars lest Christ should see
how men, their brothers, maim.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Do you wanna speak here or
at the podium? Either way.
- Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm in a peculiar position
'cause I'm blessed to be here though.
I am a lifer.
I served 100% of a 30 year
to life sentence in New Jersey's prisons.
I was incarcerated in 1988,
and I was released in 2018.
As I listened all day, it's amazing how
what we call inside, liberation education,
makes this day possible.
So for one, I'm humbled, I am blessed,
and I thank you all for creating a space
where I'm safe and I'm able to heal,
and that we can heal together.
Liberation education.
I grew up in an environment,
if you can imagine, where I
wasn't supposed to survive.
I was five, four, 118 pounds,
never incarcerated before,
and I was sentenced to 30 years to life.
And I didn't go to a youth facility.
I went straight to an adult male facility,
and I was sent there
to die or to be fodder
for the other bigger, stronger people.
But I remember meeting two
men at the orientation,
and they asked me a question.
What are you gonna do, play
basketball and be in a yard
or go to school and get an education?
Prior to my incarceration,
education has always been my safe space.
My mother abandoned me and
my brother and sisters twice.
My father raised us, he
was an authoritarian.
And it led to a lot of what I used
to make decisions that
led me to incarceration.
But when those two men asked
me what was I gonna do,
I immediately remembered my
elementary school principal,
Ms. Fenderson, and I said, "School!"
I went to school and I got my GED
within six months after entering prison.
And then I enrolled in a college program
at Mercer County Community College
in New Jersey to get
an associate's degree.
I remember the first
semester, I got two A's.
I really didn't think I was
college material, but I was.
And I went to sign up
for the next semester,
and the Pell Grants were gone.
And immediately I'm like,
"What are you doing?"
I finally find something
I like, I enjoy, I'm safe,
and I'm in a maximum security prison.
But I quickly learned
that the most violent people
don't like to be around books.
Right, if you're in the library,
if you are in the law library,
they don't go around books
or classrooms too tough.
They hang around on the cell blocks
and they wanna run the block,
they wanna run the phone,
they wanna run the mess hall,
they wanna control the haircuts,
and all the things that are,
don't really mean anything.
All I cared about was,
is that clock gonna keep
moving so I can get outta here?
I was blessed to be
around my prison father,
Mr. Jerome Perkins.
And I began to quickly learn
from him the pearls of
structural violence, right,
and how systems became
structurally violent,
whether you participated in 'em or not.
So we began to chart a course
to get education back in prison
that took us 28 years to get it back.
And I remember getting higher education
back into New Jersey State prisons
by writing a white
paper to the legislators
that went in a slew of
bills 4202 in New Jersey.
And they took the section
to make education mandatory
in all New Jersey's
prisons as it was written.
And I remember, she's
an old, she's assembly,
she was assembly woman then,
she is now in the House
of Representatives,
then assembly woman,
Bonnie Watson Coleman,
and a few, Grace Spencer and
Cohen and a few others came in,
and we did our presentation,
and education became mandatory
inside New Jersey's prisons.
Did I ever think that that was possible,
that they would listen to us?
And then we began to see that it wasn't
that we inside the carceral
space didn't have voices,
it was that our voices were silence.
And it took people coming
from the outside to the inside
to magnify those voices.
And so the senators and the
legislators started coming in,
and they began to take
the lead from the people
and our families that
were directly involved.
We get to the point
where I meet this wonderful
man, Mr. Peter Brooks.
I'm working, at the time,
I was working on my BA,
but at the same time,
I was going through the parole process,
which was the most depressing
and hard thing that I ever had to do.
And Mr. Brooks brought
in a detective class
on detective and
interrogations and techniques.
And I remember reading
all of these different
tropes that he brought in.
And I remember my first interview
with the New Jersey State Parole Board.
And two days prior to that
interview, Professor Brooks,
he don't like me calling him that though,
but at the time, Professor Brooks brought
in this video on the Reid
technique of interrogation.
And when I walked into the
room of the two-man panel,
they immediately began
using the Reid technique
of interrogation in my parole hearing.
And two days prior, we have to write
a reflection paper and an
analysis on this stuff.
I'm sitting there like,
"Are they serious?"
But that's what we call
liberation education, right?
If you're not religious-oriented,
but I'm very spiritual,
but I say there was some
divine intervention there,
I don't know what to
call it or what it was,
but it came in a moment
when I needed the most
to be able to understand
what was about to happen
and how the structural
violence of a system
was gonna be perpetuated against
me if I wasn't prepared educationally.
So that system was able to push me through
to the final level of the full board.
And the way the full board went
was totally different
than the two-man panel.
Now, and there's, we know
there's sharks in a room,
so they're waiting to jump out.
It's 12 people, and two of the 12
are going to attack you
for absolutely no reason
and try to provoke an emotional response
to justify keeping you in prison.
Now mind you, I said I'm a lifer.
That means I'm on parole
for the rest of my life.
I'm still a slave of
the state of New Jersey.
I have a travel pass to get here.
And Professor Ben Berger
had to be my escort
in order for my plantation
owners in New Jersey
to give me permission
to be in Connecticut.
So for anybody that
thinks slavery is over,
it is not, right?
This is why we have this national
campaign, Amendment 13th,
to remove the exception clause
from our national constitution
and state constitution all
throughout the country.
So as we began to go through this process
in the New Jersey State Parole Board,
they began to ask me, you know,
in the Reid technique, they
make you feel comfortable.
Let's talk about your
early childhood life,
your best memories, and things like that.
Then all of a sudden, wham,
let's talk about the day of your crime.
No segue, no nothing,
we just gonna get in it.
What was you thinking?
What were you feeling?
Now, let's remember, during
an entire 30-year process,
you are surviving.
You are not thinking about the very thing
that led you to that moment.
And now in this interview,
because it's not a hearing,
it's a interview to see
if you are qualified
to serve the discretionary portion
of your sentence in the community.
It is a privilege, this is not a right.
So we're going to see if our
carceral slave can come back
out amongst us under a
convict leasing type system
that we still have social
control over this person.
Sounds like a lot of philosophy, don't it?
Foucault, Hobbs, Locke, right?
But in order to associate that,
we have to have the academies,
with the academies that are inside,
building liberation education models,
to end the structural violence of systems.
So I remember,
I got to one of the
sharks and he was a psych.
90% of the New Jersey State Parole Board
are former law enforcement.
So you have to know what
audience you're speaking to.
And he said to me,
"You're a liar. Everything
you said is a farce.
It doesn't make sense.
You're in here deceiving us."
And he just went on with
a litany of insults.
And I sat there.
And he asked a question later on, he said,
"Well, you don't have anything to say?"
And I simply said,
"I'm here to answer questions.
You made a statement."
He said, so like you
guys just did, he said,
and the people in the room
all did the same thing.
His own colleagues was like, "He's right."
But that becomes critically
aware of a liberation education
to not get dragged into a conversation
that's mainly built on
accusations and not questions.
I'm here to answer
questions, nothing else.
So he said,
"Well, what do you think
about what I said about you?"
(audience chuckling)
Now again, be careful what
you send across the net.
You might not like what comes back.
And so I answered him, I said,
"I know that if I lie, if I'm deceptive,
if I'm not forthcoming in any way,
that keeps me in prison
for the rest of my life,
and I would not waste your time nor mine.
And if you feel as though I'm lying
and that I'm being deceptive,
I'm sorry you feel that way."
Because I wasn't speaking to one person,
I was speaking to 12, and
the majority who voted
would either vote to keep me
in prison or to release me.
But I remember the Sherlock Holmes
and the detective novels that
Peter Brooks brought inside
and how the questions were being asked
and answered to get to a
particular result, right?
So it's about that, you know,
that dance to not say what
I think they wanna hear,
but to exercise my own agency
and my own liberation
and take it in my hands,
and whatever happens, I
can't control the outcome.
It's not my decision, but
I can control my process.
That's it.
And it's the same way with education
and school and things like that.
I can just put forth the best ideas
that I can in a piece of, on
a paper or things like that.
But what I find,
what was the hardest thing
for me was coming home,
I was punished inside for writing.
I did seven years on and
off during my 30 years
in isolated confinement because
of my political writings.
I have yet to write anything
of my own thought when I came home.
Because I'm on parole, and
if they came in my house,
they could pull it and they could use
that as justification of putting me back.
So I'm not free, though
I'm physically free.
I was sharing with Ben, the last,
I have a new parole officer.
I have had six in four
years, and I'm on level four.
And what that means is I
see my parole officer once.
I would see him four
times a year, quarterly.
But I have a new parole
officer, and his thing is,
"That's the minimum standard.
I can see you as many times
as I want, and this and that."
I said, "Well, I have a standard,
if you can just do whatever you want,
you have broad discretion."
So we got into this back and forth thing.
So he came and did a home
visit to my apartment.
And when he walked in,
he came in triggering.
I'm very conscious about my triggers.
And when I'm triggered,
I will let people know
around me that I'm triggered,
and I'm not being aggressive or anything.
But, and I said that to him.
And so we get up in my
apartment and this guy says,
"Well, I'll be back next month."
I said, "No, you won't."
And he says, "Well, you are on parole."
I said, "Yes I am."
And I said, "I've earned level four
to not have to see you every month."
And then he said,
"Well, I feel like
you're being aggressive."
And he said, "I'm
concerned for my safety."
And he stepped back and put
his hand on his service weapon.
And when he did it, I
was like, "Oh, snap."
So I walked into my kitchen,
and he walked towards me,
and I said to him, I said,
"I thought you said that you were afraid
for your safety and that
I was being aggressive.
I'm trying to give you space
so you don't feel that way."
He says, "Imma need you to sit down."
Now I'm in my house.
So I said, "I'm not gonna do that."
I said, "Are you done with your search?
Are you done with whatever
you came here to do?"
Now we're talking liberation education.
Let's, like, really think about this.
I am telling a person in authority now
to get outta my house.
He takes his flashlight and
began to search my house
and my living room and says,
"Do you have me on YouTube?"
So I'm like, "You're really triggering."
So I open the living
room, I open the door,
'cause it's right by my
living room, and I say,
"You have to leave."
But then later on, I call
Professor Ben and was like,
"Yo, I don't know what this
guy's gonna do. I don't know."
But immediately, with our
education and how we do things,
one thing is, due process rights, right?
I'm only asking for what I'm entitled
to by due process and law.
I'm not asking for anything extra.
I'm not asking for any
particular special treatment.
The beautiful thing about
everything that happened is,
was the controversy and the abuse
of discretion allowed
me to navigate safely
using liberation education
that allowed me to survive 30 years,
and how to turn that
into a transferable skill
on the street and coming out
and saying, I, if need be,
how I survived 30 years through books,
through those very things that
you talked about, book clubs.
We had over 1,500 books in
East Jersey State Prison.
We have our own library that we built.
They banned the new Jim Crow. Really?
Like "Blood In My Eye," if
you got caught with that,
it is six months solitary confinement.
Contraband immediately.
You're going to the hole.
Right?
But my grandmother,
who is Native American,
she would introduce me to Red Cloud.
And Red Cloud had a saying
that I used every day
while I served 30 years,
"Every day is a good day to die."
Every day is a good day to die.
And I thank, I never really
got to thank Mr. Peter
for providing that lesson in that season
to liberate me from incarceration.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- I'm gonna stay sitting
just to acknowledge
that I'm on this level.
You're at that level. That
was amazing. Thank you.
I think that was really important.
Can you hear me? Let's see.
All right, I wanna, of course,
thank Peter for having me,
inviting me, organizing
this incredible symposium.
I wanna really process and appreciate
both of the panelists here and also,
in advance, thank you
for being kind to me.
And I also, I really
quickly wanna acknowledge
and thank all of the faculty here
who've taught in our
prison education program,
who serve on our faculty
advisory committees,
Caleb Smith, Elizabeth
Hinton, Randall Horton,
and also fellows and alumni of YPEI here,
people who've worked with our program.
A lot of familiar faces here,
so I'm really glad that I'm gonna spare
you my typical fundraising presentation.
(audience laughing)
Also, I see a few
members of Stop Solitary,
which is cool, yeah.
So I'm punching above my weight
here a little bit on this panel.
I'm what you would call a
practitioner, or if you're being
a little less charitable,
an administrator.
I imagine I was asked to sit on this panel
because I have something to say,
not just as someone who runs
a prison education program,
but especially also as someone who figured
out how to build one at the
most unlikely of places,
the university where we gather today.
And the short story is, we
found the glitch in the matrix.
What I'd like to do with
my brief time is telling
you just a little bit about
the program here at Yale
and through our partnership
with University of New Haven
and what it is that we do for context,
and then highlight some
details and vignettes
from the overlap of the twin institutions
of the prison and the university
that touch on the larger
theme of the symposium,
incarceration and imagination,
and also this panel,
which has been titled,
Incarceration,
Decarceration, and Education.
And because I work deeply within
institutional bureaucracies
of the prison and the university,
one of the things I set
out to do for myself
and agreeing to sit on this panel
is use it as an opportunity
for my own reflection
about the acts of imagination that were
and are required in order
for this program to exist.
So the program was, in
a way, in its own way,
created by incarcerated students.
The seed of origin
is through Wesleyan Center
for Prison Education,
where myself and other
faculty and graduate students
at Yale had been volunteering
for years and years.
Around the time that I started
volunteering at Cheshire
through Wesleyan's prison
education program in 2014,
it was a semester,
I was supposed to be
writing my dissertation.
So, of course, I was looking
for any excuse for distraction.
I kept finding on campus that there were
a lot of different faculty here
who were really invested
in this, who were excited,
who were excited about teaching in prison,
who thought it was really important,
and that it really made
serious their vocation
in a way that teaching
on campus maybe hadn't.
And so as I started going in more and more
and meeting more of these faculty
and graduate students
who were deeply invested
in Wesleyan's program or Bard's program
at the Bard Prison Initiative,
the students at Wesleyan encouraged
me to start a program at Yale.
They knew that, well, first they thought
there's a lot of prisons in this state,
and a lot of them don't
have programs like ours.
And if you could start a program at Yale,
it would really benefit a lot of people.
This was at Cheshire.
And they said some of us had
to transfer from other prisons
just for the shot at
applying to this program.
But they also, in that
program, knew that a program
at Yale would have more
than just a direct impact.
It would have a national impact.
It would inspire other
institutions of higher learning,
competitive institutions
who, as we all know,
only do things to outdo each other,
that it would create this ripple effect.
And that it could be hugely important.
If we could start a program at Yale,
other programs could look to us and say,
"Yale did it, we can, too."
And that was inspiring to me
to think about the possibilities
if we could get that far.
So a few of us started gathering together,
the faculty, I wanna call out Ron Jenkins
who's been teaching in
prison for a long time.
Ron was there at our first meeting
of Yale faculty who'd
been teaching in prison
and who really wanted to
brainstorm, this was 2014 or 2015.
How would we start a program
here? How would we do it?
There had never before
been a student in prison
who could say they were
part of a real Yale program.
And there had never been a program
that offered real Yale credits.
And we also counted among us
formerly incarcerated students
and graduate students on our campus
who'd been alumni of
college and prison programs
who were in graduate school or
who were undergraduates even.
We convened a small meeting
to do this imaginative work together.
What would this program look like,
and how would we pull it off?
As an aside in working
to build this program,
I spent some time considering the history
of admissions at Ivy League universities.
Of course, the story of inclusive changes
in admissions here and
elsewhere is not ever the story
of a spontaneous and benevolent increase
in access to the campus,
but a story of resistance by
small and subordinate groups.
And that is indeed the story
of how our program was started.
It was one of a fierce coalition
of faculty, staff,
students, administrators,
many, many administrators
and many offices,
the registrar's offices who,
for whatever reason, believed in it.
Formally incarcerated students
as well who came to campus,
attended meetings with deans at Yale
and also with commissioners of correction,
and who pushed until the program
finally seemed inevitable,
which it still seems (chuckles).
But one lesson I learned along the way
that I thought this might
be a good forum to share
is that it appeared to me in
this time that the university,
and this is a cynical observation
that maybe we can think about together,
but the university is built specifically
to preempt any one student or individual
from creating real impact
in under four years.
Four years is the amount of time it takes
to create any sort of lasting change.
I don't know how to subvert that sort
of rule of thumb that
I've come to understand.
But in those four years that
we pushed for this program,
an incredible shift
happened on this campus.
And many of the deans or registrars
that we met with at the beginning
who truly looked at me and said,
"I don't physically understand
what you're talking about.
Do you mean inmates are coming to campus?"
And I'd say,
"No, you know, faculty are gonna
drive themselves to prison,
you know, and then they're
gonna be in a classroom.
And in that classroom, they'll,
you know, to really paint the picture.
And, you know, we came
out on the other side,
and some of those deans are some of,
you know, the best evangelists
of this program today.
So today, we have a program
that operates year-round
through a partnership with
the University of New Haven.
We offer both Yale and
UNH classes for credit
with faculty and sometimes
graduate students
from both institutions teaching.
Students are matriculated
in an AA in general studies
and a BA in interdisciplinary studies.
If students are released before
they complete their degree,
they can seamlessly transition
to on-campus enrollment at UNH,
which is very unique in this field.
Together, we have facilitated
431 unique enrollments
in credit-bearing courses
with 121 faculty staff
and graduate students
from both campuses
teaching, guest lecturing,
or otherwise offering access
to their on-campus research and teaching.
And over 200 undergraduate
students have worked
with us as volunteers or
tutors in various capacities.
This semester, we'll
graduate our first students
from the degree program.
And today, students at
Danbury Federal Prison,
or women, rather, at the
just, you know, nearby from here,
are receiving admissions letters
to our first cohort for a
new program at that facility.
We've also just been approved
to facilitate Federal
Pell Grants in prison
as a part of this national
movement that Antonne mentioned
to restore Pell Grant
access for students inside.
And there is a lot to be proud of,
and yet also a lot that is wrong
with how things have evolved.
There are things that, you know,
we didn't succeed at in
building this program.
And there are things that I believe
we still will succeed at.
And a lot of this work requires
a lot of imaginative thinking.
And I'll get to that in just a second,
but I do quickly, and then I'm gonna end.
I just have several
discrete acts of imagination
from our prison education program
that were required to
build and to sustain it,
right, in addition to
what I just mentioned,
continuing to imagine the
ideal version of this program.
But the first was,
over those years of building
it, building a program
for an imaginary group of students, right?
Working with current
students in another program,
knowing students from other programs,
but nevertheless, fighting
through these institutions,
the Department of Corrections
and an institution of higher education
to create a credit-bearing
or degree-granting program
for a group of students that
you don't personally know.
Right?
And so, you know, a group of students
who simply have not, you know,
have not applied to the program, right?
And which is why one of the best days
in our lives as, you know,
prison education administrators
is admitting a new cohort
of students to a prison,
admitting a new cohort of students
to a prison education program,
sitting down with them,
and really saying, "This is for you."
You know, this is being in that room
and especially with our first cohorts
at any prison is really, you
know, the perfect culmination
of imaginative thinking.
Not the perfect culmination,
a good, a fine culmination.
Another act of imagination,
reading a student handbook
to students in prison.
It's one of the core principles
of this program is really,
we're extending access to
the same college classes,
the same programming that
we offer to students here.
And we hold to the same
rules and regulations,
we hold to the same standards,
and we sit there on the first
day and read every little rule
that students are trusted to read
on their own here on campus.
And reading that student
handbook is a little bit odd,
because some of these
rules simply don't apply.
But the work that it does
is in helping the students
to understand themselves as students,
as peers to students on our campus,
that they are bound to those
same ways of being a student.
A third act of imagination
is the way we constantly use
and reimagine the Yale mission statement.
We use, as our mission statement for YPEI,
the mission statement of Yale College,
to seek exceptionally promising
students of all backgrounds
from across the nation
and around the world,
and to educate them
through mental discipline
and social experience, to
develop their intellectual,
moral, civic, and creative
capacities to the fullest.
The aim of this education
is the cultivation
of citizens with a rich
awareness of our heritage
to lead and serve in every
sphere of human activity.
So we take this mission statement
and we read it every day
through an abolitionist lens.
And the way we do that is we imagine
that if we can't imagine
together a post-carceral future,
then the leaders of that future
may very well be incarcerated
today, are incarcerated today.
And in that scenario, the
charge of the university
is to invest now in those students
as future leaders and citizens.
So you don't have to change anything
about the mission statement
to read it through that lens,
but it is a way that we have to work
to imagine it serving a different purpose.
My fourth act of imagination
is a little anecdote, and
then I'll cut myself off,
'cause I have many acts of imagination.
(audience chuckling)
Creating Yale within the prison
is an interesting practice for us.
If you can imagine, our
faculty, our volunteers,
and our staff are a certain
subset of Yale citizens.
And we, you know, we bring
in a lot of, you know,
a lot of the faculty that you see here.
And there's a lot of
undergraduates who volunteer
who are students of color or
who are radical activists,
who believe, you know,
there's a lot of community
in the people who enter the prison.
And I remember one day a couple years ago,
we had a sort of, as Peter mentioned,
I went to undergrad and grad school here,
and we had a student who was volunteering
who maybe more fit you traditionally,
he was like a little very
tall lacrosse player,
very white and blonde.
And he came into the prison,
and, you know, our students
are mostly black and brown
from, you know, neighborhoods
in Connecticut cities.
And they looked at this guy and they said,
"He doesn't look like
a Yale student to me."
(audience laughing)
And I was like, "Yeah, we've
created like an ERNM college
(audience laughing)
at McDougal Walker
Correctional Institution."
And it was a really strange feeling,
'cause especially, a couple of
years ago when this happened,
we were really, there
wasn't very much interest
in teaching or learning in the program.
We had, you know, some interest,
but that semester, we had Rod Ferguson
and Lisa Lowe and Dan HoSang
and Liam Irakork coteaching ERNM
because that was all we could do.
And so, you know, having
that kind of reality check
was really, it was a weird moment,
but it also helped me think
about how we have created
this version of Yale.
We've imagined this version
of Yale within the prison.
Okay, and I'm gonna end with
just a little reflection
and something maybe
slightly uncomfortable.
I'm super grateful to be
sitting here next to Antonne.
There's something a little bit
strange about being at this,
I don't have an answer to this.
This is just my notes.
A little bit strange about being
at a symposium with scholars and writers,
and everyone's got a
friend in prison, you know,
or a person they write letters
to or about or who they teach or refer to.
It's a little bit itchy.
But it also does this
really important work
we were talking earlier about
making the invisible visible,
bringing to the forefront
of discussion people
who are hidden from view,
people actively, currently in prison.
And am I out of time?
- Just us, you know, so.
- Yeah, yeah, okay.
I just had like a little paragraph,
but a little bit off topic,
but my background is in film studies.
And one thing I've written about
is background actors
in classical Hollywood.
So in the '20s and '30s,
there were these cycles of prison films
that fetishized using
actual prison locations,
often with the permission
of like a very enthusiastic
Hollywood-hungry warden.
And then beyond that, they
would use actual prisoners
in the backgrounds of the films.
And in most of these scenarios,
it was required by the prison
and by the motion picture industry
that the background actors
could not be portrayed
in any degree of specificity
lest they require fair compensation.
So sometimes, in the backgrounds
of films that would take place in prison,
you'd see people who were incarcerated,
but they were masked in order
to suppress their identity,
their portrait, you see.
And I wasn't even gonna talk about this,
but after the rest of the,
I was sort of thinking about it,
and I'm thinking about this history
and the work that people are doing
in accompanying portraits of
individuals on the inside,
making this sort of invisible visible.
And yeah, that's it. I'll end there.
Thanks.
(audience applauding)
- Thanks, Zelda.
I wanna leave some time, if I can,
too for some questions from the audience.
I'm sure after these
terrific presentations,
there will be some.
So I'm Ben Berger, Swarthmore College.
Like Tracey Meares before
me, I'm gonna try to respond
not just to the terrific
presentations we've had here,
but also to some of the things
that have been said earlier in the day
and even from at the dinner
last night for presenters
to try to give, maybe,
a little bit of a sense
of all the things that
tie, have tied us together.
I'm really grateful,
as others are as well,
to Peter for bringing us together.
And there's this kind of simpatico
on this particular panel.
I met Peter when I was at Princeton.
I was the Rockefeller visiting professor
for distinguished teaching there,
and he had been the same
thing a few years before.
We connected through that.
I was teaching a class,
an Inside-Out class,
that is said brought Princeton students
into East Jersey State Prison,
and they took a class alongside
the incarcerated students.
That was something that Peter
was interested in doing as well.
We talked a lot about that.
He had taught at EGSP,
he had taught Tone, who
had come home already,
and Tone became my guide to figure out.
I was experienced at prison teaching,
but every institution is different,
and you've gotta figure
out what to do where.
and the kind of advice I got
from Tone was just invaluable.
And it wasn't just at the
beginning of the semester,
it was throughout the semester.
Bernard and I have talked about
and know a lot of people in common
because we've gone to
some of the same schools.
He's just done a lot more than I have,
but I don't hold that against him.
And his book "Critique
and Praxis" is fabulous,
and you should get it,
because it's informed my thinking
about some of what we're
talking about today.
It's a recent book,
and it's not just if you wanna
understand critical theory,
but also if you really wanna understand,
actually, what a critical theorist
and one who's also an activist might do
in pushing back against himself,
always questioning, am I doing enough?
Am I doing the right thing?
Which is something that all of
us ought to be doing really.
The overarching theme that I wanna talk,
bring together is the one of imagination.
Bernard reminds us with the example
of reading groups in the carceral spaces.
Antonne reinforces with
his really moving examples
of them that things don't happen.
We don't build things unless
we can imagine them, right?
Unless they already happen
to us in our experience
or if we can imagine them.
And books are one way of doing that.
And not just books,
but then talking about books
with other people as well.
So that's the basic power of imagination
to help us to figure out what
we might be able to build,
that just can't be underestimated.
I wanna recount a few
things from other panels
to set the stage for what
we are talking about here.
Joy James, this morning, wondered
about the protective mechanism
that authors of fiction
might be able to offer the incarcerated
if some incarcerated people
have difficulty being seen by the public.
Now Caleb pointed out
that there are some truths
that people in power don't
want incarcerated writers
to tell or other writers to
tell about the incarcerated.
There's a double bind.
You wanna say the right
thing but not say too much
and not get in trouble
with the powers that be.
And Rachel Kushner shared with us
that story of the poetry editor
that said for a prisoner's bio,
they could include only the person's name,
age, where they were incarcerated,
and the crime for which
they were convicted.
That was the bio. Nothing
else about the person.
There was a kind of
vanishing, a kind of erasure.
A strict control over the resources
that readers might be able to access
when they create the film in their mind
of thinking about life for
that incarcerated person.
And I think most of us agree
that's not an accident.
It's not an accident.
There is strict control.
Telling the story you told
about the the parole officer
even outside the prison and
the control that's exercised,
it's not an accident.
One of the things that
struck me most forcefully
when I started doing prison teaching
was this intentional erasure
of bodies and personalities,
a vanishing of people, not
just from the broader public,
but sometimes even from families as well,
the inability to bring pictures out.
My group at Princeton,
we took a class picture.
We had somebody from one
of the photography groups
coming in and take a picture of us.
I smuggled that out.
I wasn't supposed to have
it get out of the prison.
It seems ridiculous.
Why shouldn't we have
a picture of us there?
But we weren't, all right?
Even images weren't supposed to go out.
And so it's one of the
reasons why I appreciate
not only prison education
programs in general,
like Zelda, the one you've created here
and my hat is off to you,
but especially the Inside-Out model
that was created at Graterford Prison,
now called the Phoenix
and Temple University.
So I practice the Inside-Out model,
people all over the world do it as well.
That is where, like at
Princeton that one year, right?
You have a class inside
the carceral facility.
And there are students
from your home institution,
they're the outside students
together with the incarcerated students,
they're the inside students,
and you're reading the same books,
you're writing the same papers,
having the same discussions,
they are transformative.
But what they also do is
they allow outside students
to go home and realize
and tell other people too,
this is the kind of erasure, I
saw what's actually going on,
and it's not what's
being portrayed out here.
So it's one way in which,
a little way in which their imaginations
and what they convey to
others can be expanded
in terms of possibly
changing things as well.
Zelda, this great work you've
done, again, here with Yale.
We're trying around Swarthmore
and in Pennsylvania more
broadly to create our own kind
of prison education
system, we're well filipa.
I mean, Villanova's got
its own great program,
but PA doesn't, we're trying to kind
of copy what's in New Jersey.
I learned so much about
NJ-STEP through Ton,
at where there is one central
school, that's Rutgers,
that grants the BAs no
matter who at what school,
Drew, Princeton, wherever,
might teach a class inside,
but Rutgers is the
BA-granting institution.
And then Raritan Valley Community College
is the AA-granting institution.
We're trying to do something
like that with Penn State as the main one,
so that when I teach a course inside,
my students have credit
towards a Penn State degree
or a community college degree.
But here's the thing,
and I wanna raise this to
Bernard and also to Zelda.
This is not really a critique.
It's where I wanna lift something
up as kind of an
expansion, not a critique.
And it came up last night at dinner
with Rich Rivera and Tone.
We had a fabulous conversation
about inside life,
but also coming home and reentry
and about parole boards as well.
And Rich made the really interesting point
that, I mean, shouldn't
come as a surprise to us,
but sometimes you gotta
gotta have things brought
to the level of consciousness
to really deal with them,
that, of course, we don't
want to just hold everybody
inside before they come home
or before they're considered a success
that they are like Tone or Rich.
People you've met who have come home
often are just amazing people.
They would've succeeded
anywhere in the world.
They're people who had the drive
to go through a college degree,
to become paralegals, to
do all kinds of stuff.
But there are many paths to success,
and it doesn't have to come
necessarily just through books,
a particular kind of book,
a particular kind of discussion group.
That doesn't invalidate.
I mean, we are dedicated to that.
We're intellectuals, we're academics.
Rich pointed out that if you
play basketball for 20 years,
you're dedicated to that.
It takes more than we can recognize
because it's a scarce resource.
Courts are a scarce resource.
Being able to stay dedicated,
focused, stay out of trouble,
the many different things you've gotta do
to be able to do that for 20, 25 years,
that's stuff that will
work on the outside too.
That's stuff that needs
to be recognized as well.
So it may be one thing that some
of us here can try to lift
up to the broader public
who can put pressure on
parole boards to say,
"Well, it's not just one way.
You don't have to be someone
who's got a perfect GPA
or something to be able to come home."
Again, that's an
expansion, not a critique,
I think, of what you
guys are working towards.
And Zelda, I was asking
Zelda this before this,
but I'd love to talk afterwards
too about the possibility
of bridge programs
for folks who aren't ready right away
to come in and start a college
program inside, but want to.
Having tutors in place,
having Yale tutors in place
or wherever the school
is to help get them to the level
where now you're ready
to start, all right?
And so we're not only
dealing with people who say,
"I wanna read Mao right now.
I wanna read Marx right now."
Right?
So there's lots of paths
to that kind of success I'm drawn to.
Let me just say one thing
about imagination broadly.
It was the theme of today.
So we talked about, like, visibility,
and Tracey gave a great
little sort of pushback
about visibility, well,
maybe that's not enough,
'cause some things are visible,
but they don't necessarily lead to change.
We may ignore them, we may
push back against them.
So what I wanna specify with imagination
is that imagination needs
building blocks, it needs food,
not food for thought,
but food for imagination.
So I think a little bit of Thomas Hobbes,
you don't have to like Hobbes'
overall political theory
or even endorse his adamistic
approach to the world
to like this, what I'm
gonna put out there.
He says that,
"Imagination, it's
particles. It's particulate."
So since the world meets us
here through our experiences,
our sense organs process
that, and then afterwards,
the kind of echoes of that,
they become available to us.
These faint imprints as imagination.
But it's only things
we've encountered already.
You can't imagine something
you had no idea about.
You might encounter it
through somebody else telling
you about it or through your experience.
We need food, we need particles
to feed the imagination.
And Zach said something
earlier about novelists,
possibly being able to order and organize
the particles that the
rest of the world sees.
That's what I wanna put out there.
There's lots of
information that could come
out to make things less
invisible about prisons.
But we need people who are gonna be able
to organize the particles into something
then they can expand a popular imagination
about what's actually happening
and what could happen as well.
So I heard a lot of
sub-themes like that today.
I just wanna kind of lift that up.
I hear that in today's panelists as well.
To build, to rebuild, to reform,
reboot, to revolutionize,
we have to be able to imagine it.
Now, just 'cause you can imagine something
doesn't mean that it's possible.
You can imagine flying pigs
and maybe genetic engineering will,
I don't know what that's
gonna come up with,
but right now they're not possible.
So it may not be sufficient,
but it's necessary.
You gotta be able to imagine it.
And that's what we've gotta expand.
So let me see, I see
only a couple more things
so I can get to some other questions
and comments on the panelists, right.
Ton, when we go to
questions and conversation,
I'd love to invite you
to expand on something
that we've talked about before,
and you've also talked about with Bernard,
with Zelda, with Peter
on different occasions
about a way of expanding imagination
through changing the rhetoric,
and no longer talking
perhaps about just crime,
but about public health,
the public health model.
I'd love to invite you to
do that once I wrap up here.
I think it's really deep,
and it shows the importance
of rhetoric to organize the particles,
to be able to get people on board.
Because here's the other thing.
I think we're not, often,
folks here are probably pretty much
on the same page when it comes to a lot
of issues regarding the carceral state,
to a lot of issues regarding injustice
and what needs to change.
But it's a big country,
and not everybody agrees.
And we've seen some horrifying
examples of polarization,
and yet you need other people,
unless you just wanna think
that a very small band are
gonna change everything,
and we saw that kind of on January 6th,
and it thankfully didn't work out.
But unless you wanna go that path,
you need a lot of people to be brought in.
And so you may need to put things
in other languages as well.
I sometimes wonder if
it wouldn't be better
to have something like a
situation comedy written
by incarcerated folks but at
many different institutions
so that the stories they're talking
about couldn't be recognizable
all coming from one place.
But their stories,
real stories within
characters who are humanized,
for lack of a better word,
to the larger population.
Sitcoms and popular culture,
music also, hiphop music,
those things get through
to a lot of people
in the way that languages often don't,
and can create the
atmosphere for social change.
So I don't care if it's a
sitcom or what the thing is.
I just mean stories that go out there
that aren't just accusatory
and that actually say,
actually, we, a lot of us,
share the same things here.
A lot of us know people who are in prison.
A lot of us have relatives,
whether we are living in
this part of the country,
that part of the country,
we're all hurt by this.
Our communities are hurt when people
are taken out of the the workforce.
Our families are hurt
when parents are taken
out of the parenting environment.
And that's something that we all share.
So I wanna advice to think about,
together, different ways
beyond also just the academic,
although I am an academic, of course.
All right, last thing,
engaged scholarship.
Peter mentioned that I direct
the center at Swarthmore.
Its focus is engaged scholarship.
It used to be community-based learning.
When I came in,
we changed it to engaged
scholarship because it's broader.
It lets a lot more faculty
in who are doing maybe
things on public policy,
maybe things that aren't
just about working
in a particular local community.
Ernest Boyer coined that term.
What he meant by it
was engaged scholarship
is turning, orienting the
resources of the university
towards our most pressing public problems,
issues, ethical issues,
civic issues, et cetera.
However, what Boyer missed was this.
It's more than that now.
What we try to do now
is prospective-taking.
You've gotta be problem-solvers with folks
who are affected by stuff, not for them.
That's what this work is doing.
It's why all the kind of educational stuff
you're talking about do is so important.
It's what Tone and I have done together.
Tone and other people at EGSP made me see,
I just never thought about it before.
Those who are making policy
for reentry, all right,
have no experience with reentry
at all themselves, all right.
Being informed by people who are inside
who are about to come out,
those who have recently come
out, and their families,
who actually know something
about what's needed
is just the obvious way to go.
In fact, it seems idiotic
to do it any other way,
and yet we do it every other way but that.
So I just wanna call on
even more doing things
with to be able to get better solutions.
That's the kind of thing I'm inspired
by today a lot of people doing with,
and doing with expands our
imagination tremendously.
So thanks very much for
everyone being here.
(audience applauding)
And to you all, thanks.
- Yeah, let's have
questions for one another
to one another for a few minutes,
and then we'll open it to the audience.
- To answer Ben's question, while inside,
one of the biggest hurdles to
get over was public safety.
How do you bring in a chess program
and play Princeton University students
when it's a threat to public safety,
it's threat to the people
that are coming into the institutions,
and it's a threat that if
someone takes a hostage
to the safety of the guards
and the how they run things?
So what we did was,
through what we call liberation education,
we was introduced to a concept
called Public Health, right?
This is a way of changing the
health of this institution.
And it's at the time
I was incarcerated in
Trenton State Prison,
now known as New Jersey State Prison.
I did 20 years there, and I
did my last 10 at East Jersey.
And what wind up happening was,
when we won that first argument
by framing it through
a public health lens,
this'll reduce violence,
this'll reduce different things,
it'll teach cognitive
thinking, critical engagement.
It'll do a lot of things just with this.
So our first, our tournament
was with Princeton.
We had 60 people, but I think
Trenton is 1,100 people.
800 signed up.
And then it became an
instrument to incentivize.
And we wind up being in, on
ESPN while we were inside.
Most people don't look
at chess as a sport,
but chess is a sport, right?
So when I tell the youth
that I work with right now
in Rutgers Youth Success
program in Camden,
I said, "You know I was on the ESPN."
"Mr. Tone, you cappin'."
(audience laughing)
I'm like, "And I was in
'Sports Illustrated'."
"Yeah, right. Right. You
ain't got no game like that."
- [Ben] I've got the
article on my computer here
if you wanna see it later on, yeah.
- Yeah, so and a lot of people,
like when I open it up, and it was like,
"Well, how was y'all able
to do that in there?"
And I said, "Through the
public health space, right?
And a harm reduction strategy."
And it greatly reduced
institutional violence,
because people wanted to
get into the chess club
in order to play against
Princeton like the elite,
like they thought they were something
and they would do all of that.
And what wound up happening
was, when I got to East Jersey,
that's how we introduced the concept
to the administrators and the commissioner
of corrections using a
public health argument.
I've never lost a public
health argument institution.
Right, and coming home and bringing
that same carceral
organizing to the community,
it's like, you know, I remember,
I've never been to Brooklyn in my life.
I only seen Brooklyn in
the movies and on TV.
And I went to Brooklyn, and we
were in this housing project,
and I remember giving a
presentation and saying,
"Well, we don't have
to defund the police."
Right?
I said, "All we have to do is repurpose
the money to public health
and address the public health
and treatment as opposed to punishment."
And you can continue to do
what you want over here,
but we are gonna address it
through a public health lens
and a harm reduction strategy.
And what wind up happening was,
one of the side effects of the talks
is when I got off the
stage and I walked down,
the police started surrounding me,
and immediately, I got triggered,
and I'm thinking, "Oh my
God, what did I say now?"
Like I'm, you know, here we go.
And they all came, and
when they surrounded me,
they was like, "I did not understand
what you said about, we didn't
have to defund the police.
Can you explain it?"
I said, "If we strictly focus on dealing
with the social issues
through a public health model
and a harm reduction strategy,
there's money already sitting there
in surplus that we're not using.
There's billions and
billions of dollars there,
and it's not reaching the communities
that desperately need them,
especially black and brown communities."
So I remember, it was Sergeant Morgan,
he's probably the only second officer
that I ever shook hands with.
And he was like, "Can I
have your phone number
and can I have your email address?"
So I'm looking at my guys, Umar Dollard,
and most of the people that I work
with have served in
ordinance amount of time.
The minimum is 28 years.
The highest is 52 years.
And we imagined, while we were inside,
we have our own school that we purchase
from the Board of Education
in the city of Camden.
We have our own studio,
we have our own cameras,
green screen production, we
have our own business district.
But because we imagined
it when it didn't exist
and came home and manifested
through a public health agenda
and a harm reduction strategy.
- We have a very patient audience.
I think we should give them a voice now,
if that's okay with the rest of you.
- [Ben] Yes, yes, yes, yes.
- Questions.
Yes.
- There's a mic somewhere.
- Yes, right there. Yeah.
- [Charlie] It's on?
Hi, my name is Charlie.
First of all,
I would like to thank you
guys for having this event.
I found out about it on Facebook.
I served about two decades,
came home recently,
and I'm still shaking off the shackles
of being institutionalized.
And I would just like to invite anybody
that would like to pick my
mind, maybe, through my,
I have a mountain of experience
and knowledge on this topic,
and I would just like to
give back in any way I can.
So if anybody would like to reach
out and pick my mind, I'm here.
You can catch me at
charlierockldprisonmentality@gmail.com.
- Welcome home, Charlie.
- Thank you, guys.
- Welcome home. Yeah, yeah.
(audience applauding)
- Rachel.
- [Rachel] Yes, a question
for any of the five
of you who would care to answer it.
Thanks, those presentations were amazing.
Just, I sometimes, sorry,
I was gonna elect myself of
sort of state of Missouri,
not of the state, but as
a Californian, we have a,
the scope and particularity
of our prison system
is maybe somewhat unique, but the,
you know, it's very unnatural, I think,
that incarceration involves
a separation of the genders.
And women's prisons in California,
I'm sorry to generalize but I'm going to,
because I would really love to hear
what you all think about this.
Like, the culture of learning
and intellectual strength
and enriching the mind
and having an interior life
that is inviable by the
staff and the guards,
that is not really robust in
California women's prisons.
And I've had long conversations
with people inside prison about this,
and people explain things to
me about why it's not robust,
and they have real reasons like,
"You don't understand
what it's like in here.
Most people come from profound trauma.
They're trying to order
their mind all the time
and deal with a kind of
high-drama environment
where there's eight people
to a room, et cetera,
et cetera, and no one has privacy."
And so it is has not been
one of the main avenues
to a kind of psychic or
mental liberation for people.
And I was wondering if you could just talk
about your experiences as
teachers and as students
and whether this comes up in other places.
Is California unique in that way?
And if not, like, how to think
about this uneven distribution
of forms of liberation
through intellectual work through reading.
- Can you address that?
Do you guys do both?
- So like I said, we
started our programming
in the federal women's prison today,
this morning (chuckles).
People were delivered
their admissions letters.
So I can't speak with
much expertise about,
I mean, I am, I'll tell you,
women's prisons are different, you know.
We've, you know, already
in just the short while
that we've been, you know,
we had information sessions
and ran interviews there,
but I do think, I mean, I'm not sure
what security level those prisons are.
There is, you know, what
you describe sounds similar
to the environment of this prison
where we're working, which is essentially,
I mean, it is literally a warehouse
that was purchased by
the Bureau of Prisons
and converted into a satellite location
for the federal prison.
And so the women who are there
are in one large gymnasium type room.
And so the boundaries
between people are not,
you know, there's a lot of,
you know, I think, I mean,
I think, I suspect you might be right,
but I really don't know in particular,
but I do think that security level
has a lot to do with what is
possible and able to happen,
which is a little bit of an oxymoron,
'cause we found in the
high maximum adult prison
where we work, which is, you know, not,
no prison is where anybody should be,
or ideal, but it's especially not ideal,
but people at least have some alone time
and then they have communal
time in the prison where we are.
At the women's prison where
women are put in one room,
there isn't that alone,
we really are gonna have to build
it out right, spaces especially.
Spaces are really
important in this context.
Finding a space for people to have a group
that is able to meet not just once a week,
but every single day.
You know, like, to be in an environment
where you can imagine
yourself as a college student,
not just Wednesday
evenings, but all the time.
- Yeah, you know, I think it's fair to say
that women have, within
this space of the invisible,
women in prison have been the invisible,
within the invisible throughout much
of the history since the 1970s.
And, but I think, you know,
I think it's gonna be context
and history and person-specific.
In New York, a lot of the work
and the teaching I've been doing at Rikers
has been at Rose's, which
is the women's facility.
And there was a big emphasis
on providing courses
from Columbia at Rose's in particular.
And the Columbia Justice
and Education program
in part was built by Kathy
Boudin and Cheryl Wilkins
and has really dedicated a
lot to the Bedford facility.
So in part, I think it's gonna
be somewhat path-dependent
on who it is that's doing the work
and spearheading the
efforts and stuff, you know.
- I see a few.
It's, you raise an interesting question,
and which is, the irony
is we look to California
and the writings from
California on the East Coast,
and they're on the West Coast.
And what you just proposed was sort
of what reminds me of
what just happened in the,
well, it's been happening for quite
a while in Edna Mahan and New Jersey,
with the beatings and
the rapes and the things
of women and where they have
this institution, right?
So one of the things is,
what I was anexing in
a lot of our protests
was the location of the prison, right?
You treat it the same way
you treat domestic violence
people, women, and how they do.
The first thing they did was isolate them.
Right?
They put 'em in a far out place
where nobody can get to 'em.
That's what most DV violators do. Right?
So the institution is not by
any public transportation.
You can't get there by
train, bus, or anything,
and they're remote.
And that isolation, and
that isolation serves
as a means of social control
inside the carceral space.
And when you do it that
way, right? It's by design.
So what they're manifesting
and what they're explaining to you.
So it's like, when I began to,
we have a program called
Meet Him At The Gate.
And it started with
anybody that's coming home.
We go to the institutions
no matter how far.
Well, New Jersey is a pretty
densely popular state,
so we can get to all, right
now, I think we have nine,
we can get to all nine, but
Edna Mahan is the hardest.
But then I quickly learned
that I was ill-equipped
to handle the needs of women
coming home from incarceration.
I don't know what to buy a woman,
I don't know what a five six
is or zero or nothing like that.
I don't know how to do those things.
So what I did was I began to collaborate
with Casavere who came home
who also served time at Edna Mahan,
and then she took Meet Him at the Gate
and turned it into Meet Her at the Gate
and addressed and then was
duplicating what we were doing
on the male side for the female side.
And one thing we all have to
understand in this country,
women are the most underserved population
in the carceral state of America.
There's no services for them.
And that's what you are experiencing.
And the thing is that that got,
this is what this is about.
How do we begin to imagine spaces
or opportunities or tactics and strategies
to bring forth those
solutions or methodologies?
- [Audience Member] Yeah,
hi, thank you so much.
That's loud.
I've just been thinking about
this kind of all day today.
And Zelda, you mentioned
reading the mission statement
through an abolitionist lens.
Kind of hoping for or
imagining a post-carceral state
being led by those that are
currently incarcerated today.
And I'm curious, for most
of you that are working
at these larger institutions
that are still culpable
for increased policing in
black and brown neighborhoods
in under the guise of protecting
mostly white students,
how do we contend with those two truths
or multiple truths while
leading these great programs
and just existing in
those multiple realities?
- Great question. Thanks.
You know, it's, that's
obviously a big problem at Yale,
at Columbia, and many
of these institutions.
The way I've tried to think
about it is that at these institutions,
there are some people who are
doing extraordinary things
and some great centers,
centers for justice and others elsewhere.
And that there are also these
other spaces that are causing harm.
And you have to, in a way, I kind of feel
as if I don't wanna give
up claiming the space
for the good projects
by seeding the ground
to the nefast in a way.
And so, I mean, I try as much as possible
to promote and foster
and support those spaces
that are doing good and also
fighting against the other,
you know, tentacles of these
abominable institutions.
- I think Judith Resnik had
her hand up in the back there.
- [Ruth] Thanks, I just wanted to engage
a little bit more with
the gender question,
because obviously, the institutions
are constructed by and construct gender.
Women are about 10% of the
incarcerated population
and the stuff we do on
solitary black women
are way over constrained in
solitary than white women,
even though solitary is used
less in women's facilities,
in facilities designated for women
than facilities designated for men.
But I'm thinking in terms of Rachel
and some of the other comments
about in the late '70s,
the US house held hearings,
women, the forgotten offender,
apropos the left out,
not much on the screen.
Though, at the time,
the federal facilities had
no things called camps,
which are the least secure
facilities for women at all.
But after a lot of activism,
then there became a camp,
actually, at Danbury
and then a women's facility
for about 1,100 people
till the Federal Bureau of Prisons
in about 2012, '13 decided to move,
proposed to move 1,000 women
to Aliceville, Alabama,
which is a bad place to
be if you're from Alabama,
let alone elsewhere,
because it's extremely remote
near the Mississippi border.
So the women actually who
remain, a lot of fight,
and a small facility for women remains,
and in the wake of COVID,
the, and about 100 people
got out on home confinement.
There's a group called
the Danbury 100 organized
by these amazing women
who have pulled together
and connected people who
are on home confinement
and are a big fight about
being reincarcerated there.
So I was wondering about
whether the activism engagement
for women is differently
engaged, expressed,
and/or seen even when it
exists and/or suppressed.
And also what the sort
of library resources are,
including the Inside-Out stuff
as well as the ways Kathy Boudin
and other people's activism at Bedford
was instrumental in
transforming the facility
after an enormous amount of fighting,
but she also had a huge amount of access
to resources to make visible
her conflicts around it.
So one of the projects for
the narrative imagination
would be to try to probe Rachel's
how and where and when is that,
are women's facilities
underseen, underserved,
underengaged, reengaged,
or differently engaged?
And how might one make more
accessible the work from the,
the work that's going on inside, outside,
as well as outside work going inside?
- One of the biggest hurdles
is when women come home
and they enter into relationships, right?
And most of their partners
force them back into silence.
Right?
They don't want anybody to know
that their significant
other, loved one, partner,
wife, fiance has been incarcerated.
So you go from an environment that does
that to coming home and
being in a relationship
that also continues that same process.
So when we're out in front of Edna Mahan
and we're advocating,
we're calling for services,
we're calling for not
reform but transformation
of a system that isolates
and abuses with impunity.
It was hard to organize amongst the women.
And when the ones that did come out,
that was the first time,
it was like a history in New
Jersey to be able to do that.
And I understand like,
that stigma is harder on,
I had to learn that it was harder
on women than it was on men.
Why, because they're the
mothers, they're the daughters.
Right, that gender-specific
what you ask is a lot of things
that become what we call a
new entry pop up barriers.
Right, to being able to tell that story,
to be able to go before a
Senate hearing or Capitol Hill,
wherever you have to go, right,
it's almost like they're
sworn into secrecy and silence
even after the custodial
term has been served.
And that's something
that we have to imagine.
What can we do to bring them out
and to bring them in safe spaces
where they can tell their stories,
if anonymously or specifically,
without any other harm occurring to 'em.
And that's the dilemma that we face.
- Very interesting.
Take one more question in the back there.
You've been very patient waiting.
- [Audience Member] Thank you.
I just wanted to expand on the question
of the previous person.
My name's Idamu,
and I served over 15 years
in California state prisons.
And my question is around
how y'all as educators
that go inside of prisons or run programs
that go inside of prison balance,
I heard one person talk about using
an abolitionist lens or
abolitionist mission,
how do you balance the
tension between that
and the fact that
educational programs are,
can be considered a reform?
And so, yeah, just that reforms
in fact strengthen the system,
that, you know, the history of prisons
is a history of reforms.
Just a quick story.
I went and visited Norway this summer
and toured their prison system.
And what I saw there was
a lot of the same things.
I mean, Norway has, in
some ways, done prisons
in a way that's more palatable
for their society and for the world.
And what I saw was like a lot
of different countries sending contingents
there to tour their system,
to bring it back to their countries
so that they could like quell rebellion.
And so I just think about,
you know, for myself,
like education inside was a place
just like one of y'all talked about,
where it felt non-carceral,
it felt like we could share ideas
and there wasn't the threat
of, you know, prison guards
and there was some level
of equity between students,
but that also the prison
uses that as a way
to strengthen itself and to
show like what we're doing
and what, you know, like
these are the advancements
that we're making.
And like if we have an
abolitionist vision,
like, our ultimate goal is not
to have better universities
inside of prisons,
but to like not have
prisons at all, right?
- Yeah.
- [Audience Member] And then like just to,
sorry, just, maybe that's good enough.
- No, no, no. I wanna hear.
- But I was just gonna
say that also like Yale
is not just an institution
that has a police force,
but also Yale is an institution
that functions in a lot
of ways like the prison.
It excludes certain people
and includes certain people
just in the same way that prison's doing.
So like that's also a tension
that exists too, right?
- Yes.
- So.
- I mean, the short answer is yes.
All of that is absolutely right.
But to answer the first
question, you know,
I think the way that I would answer right
is it a reformist reform or
is it a non-reformist reform?
I simply believe that what we're doing
is a non-reformist reform,
and the shortest way I
have of explaining that
is that it helps people
get outta prison, you know.
Like you heard this story,
you heard Antonne's story.
We have students who were
sentenced to life in prison,
you know, and who were able to go through,
you know, up to a parole board
or get a sentence
modification or a commutation
and for whom, you know,
having a Yale transcript
or showing that they
could enroll right away
at UNH was not a small thing, you know,
and truly led to people
being freed from prison.
And to me, investing them
with that sort of freedom,
but also, you know, power
to then be in the world
and making, you know, the
advancements towards abolition,
you know, towards, you know,
and I really appreciated
actually what Bernard said
about, you know, this,
it's a battle, right?
Yale isn't one thing, you know.
We all carry this label with us,
and then you have this responsibility
of acting with it
attached to you, you know.
it is a stigma, right?
Just that you compared Yale to the prison,
it is also a stigma, just like the prison.
And when we first started, you know,
researching for this
program, I would go to every,
you know, there's a women's
resettlement working group
and a reentry round table in New Haven.
And I'd go to every, you know,
one of these meetings
with my friend, James,
who was an alum of the Wesleyan
program and they would yell.
People from the community
would yell at us.
"Yale, you did this to me.
You did this to me. You did this to me."
And in a way like, yes, we
had to sit there and say like,
"Yes, I have benefited
from this institution
that has done a lot of,
has done every single
thing you said, you know."
And yet we're trying
to build out something
that can be a part of this, you know,
if you're imagining a
battle of good and evil,
but at least, you know, you're
staking more and more people
for this side of a cause that
is moving towards, you know,
ideally not building a perfect
university in a prison,
but building, you know,
building away from having the prison,
moving people outside of there,
investing, you know power
and leadership potential
into those, you know, students who were,
you know, identifying
and investing all of our energy and money
and everything else into.
- Really quickly, I mean,
I think all of these things
are double-edged swords
and they're complicated.
Conversion stories are
double-edged swords as well, right?
Because not everyone,
because for all the people
who've gone through conversion stories,
as Caleb was telling us,
I mean, or if the limits
of conversion stories
is all of those who've been
so damaged by the prison
that there isn't a conversion story.
And education also, all those
who, and it becomes something,
it becomes the test or the way,
or you know a way to get out of prison,
but it also fails for so many others.
So these are really double-edged swords
and complicated questions.
And I'm someone actually
who doesn't believe in
non-reformist reform.
I think non-reformist
reform is just an oxymoron,
it's just an easy way out
of a complicated situation
as an abolitionist.
But I would say that
as a personal, ethical,
as my own ethical responsibility,
I cannot simply give up on friends
and people who are in prison.
And even if it's gonna be, and even,
and so there's a point
at which there's just
an ethical responsibility
to care for others.
And one way we can do
it is through reading
and sharing and talking and thinking.
And so I don't view it as
a non-reformist reform.
I don't view revolution
as where you gotta come
to the situation where it's really
so bad that people are gonna revolt.
I think you do abolitionist
work and you also care.
And that means going in and sharing.
- Abolition, I think that's
a good note on which to end.
And I refer us back to Antonne's notion
of liberation education
as an imaginative ideal.
But I also think of the
fact that of the class
of 25 that Antonne was a member of,
so far as I know, 23 of them
still are in East Jersey.
And so liberation is a great ideal
and it also has its limitations.
Listen, we reconvene in
15 minutes at four o'clock
for our readings by Randall
Horton and Richard Rivera.
And after that, when they're done,
there'll be a reception
upstairs in room 131
to which you are all warmly invited.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
(gentle music)